(electronic music)
- Welcome to a conversation with history,
I'm Harry Kreisler of the
Institute of International Studies
Our guest today is Michael Warner
who is the Knox professor of
English and American Studies
at Yale University, he was chairman
of the English department of Yale from...
2008 to 2014, he is the 2018
Tanner Lecturer at Berkeley.
Michael, welcome to Berkeley.
- Thank you.
- Where were you born and raised?
- In the mountains of North Carolina.
In a small town in a
Pentecostalist family.
- Aha, and looking back,
how did your parents shape
your thinking about the world?
- Well, it's...
It's an early experience in
a kind of counterculture,
I suppose you might say.
But also the world of...
Pentecostalism in the
mountains in those days
was a very intense one,
but it was also a very...
Reading focused one, and as
I got a lot of acquaintance
with the Bible and a lot of
familiarity with theological
argument and that's
really the training ground
for my intellectual life.
- And was the whole family very religious?
Did you talk about religious
issues at the dinner table?
- Oh, Lord yes, and my mother...
I grew up with my mother
because she was divorced
and she had three marriages,
each of which was more unhappy
than the one before, the
more unhappy she got,
the more deep she went into
the world of faith healing
and Pentecostalism,
so it was an inescapable
element of the environment,
there were Bible studies
several times a week
and prayer meetings and
she would speak in tongues
while vacuuming the
carpet so it was constant.
- Now in your work there is a recognition
and an acceptance of the
emotional element often
in writing and speaking
and public discourse.
Is this the root of that?
- I'm sure I learned it there, absolutely.
- And so then where did, what
was your public education
like, or did you go to a religious school?
- Well, I was sent to a religious school,
Orrel Roberts University.
Which was the only university
that was really acceptable
to the family and...
And so it was quite a
while before I joined the,
what we would think of
the mainstream of secular
intellectual life, that didn't really come
til graduate school.
- And this undergraduate...
Study at Orrel, is that
primarily Biblical study,
or do they offer secular courses?
- Well, there is no philosophy department.
If you want to study philosophy, you do so
in the theology department
and fortunately I found a very sympathetic
and protective teacher who
was an English professor
and that sent me on the
path toward English.
- And was this an awakening
that occurred over time?
- Oh yeah.
- Over time.
- Oh yeah, the decompression
process was slow
and moved by stages because
I also had to deal with being
queer and it's not an easy
environment to do that in.
You would get thrown out
of course if it were open
or suspected even, so...
Yes, it took a long time
to make all the adjustments
to secular life and queer identity.
- And so, after the
Orrel Roberts experience,
you basically said, well,
I'm gonna pursue my studies
but I'm gonna move to the secular world.
Tell us a little bit
about that transition.
it doesn't sound like it's an easy one.
- No, it wasn't easy
because one of the things
about growing up in a religious subculture
is that you don't feel entitled to...
First class education, no
one ever mentioned to me
that I could have gone
to a place like Berkeley.
It was kind of unthinkable.
So first of all, just
figuring out what is the map
of institutions outside that
world, that I could attend
was a challenge, my father
had gone to the University
of Wisconsin, so that was
a kind of easy default path
and I did a master's degree there
and while I was studying at
the University of Wisconsin
I realized that everyone there
was reading all this exciting
new work that was coming
out of John Hopkins,
so somehow I decided, I
gathered up the courage
to apply to Johns Hopkins
and that's really the event
that changed my life,
that steered me in a whole
new direction.
- And what did you do
your dissertation on?
- On 18th century American literature.
It became my first book.
I got interested in how
print, the world of print,
seemed by the 19th century to
already be taken for granted
by people as the real
matrix of social life.
So I began wondering how that came to be,
when did that happen, when
did that come to be the case
and pushed my studies backward
into the colonial period.
- I like to ask my guests...
What are the skills and
temperament required for
the scholarship or the work that they do?
You are a social critic,
a literary critic, what...
Do you see in retrospect as
the skillset that goes with
these vocations?
- Well, I guess my understanding
of that changes over time
as the surrounding world changes.
I realize now that...
That world of Bible study that I came from
had trained me in very intense
sustained concentration
on a text and that I think
is something that's rarer
and rarer as people read
more and more from screens
and in a distracted state.
So I feel lucky to have
grown up in that culture
of the word, in intense
investment in the word
and the willingness to
spend a long amount of time
with a page.
So that's one thing, but the intensity of,
you used the word emotional,
I'd say the full body,
full spectrum intensity
of that world also...
Disposed me to think about
how language circulates
in the world and the full range of effects
that it creates in a social life.
- And what about temperament?
- Well...
There's a kind of polemical
disposition in that religious
subculture that I guess carried
over into academic life.
This was a world in
which churches regularly
went through schisms of various kinds.
We were always picking up
and moving to another church
because the preacher
seemed not quite orthodox
on a certain point or
we became less orthodox
on a certain point or something like that.
So the primacy of argument
and the strong feeling
that went with argument was I
guess something that carried
over into intellectual life,
although I've also learned to
not cast people into hell
for disagreeing with me.
- It's interesting because
you grew up in an enclosed
environment, so to speak,
and then you moved to
the larger secular world.
- Exactly.
- Now in your work, there is
a focus on marginal groups.
- Yes.
- On outsiders.
- On the integrity
of those groups.
- Yes.
- On the extent to which they can affect
social transformation
in the larger society,
so these...
- Absolutely.
- Various experiences were
a kind of training, I guess,
for the focus that your
intellectual life would take.
- Absolutely, I am keenly
sensitive to the tendency
to foreclose the world of the acceptable
and create various margins or boundaries
and whenever I perceive
that there is someone
outside the boundary of the
normal or the acceptable,
my ears go up and I want
to learn more about that
and I think there is a kind of,
for many of us who have
been through a formative
experience like that, there's
a kind of translatability
between one kind of counterculture
sensibility and another
Once you are willing, once
you have the experience
of being willing to stand
outside the mainstream
and you know that you'll
survive and you know
that you'll find other
people who are likeminded...
It opens you to other formations like that
and you are less willing
to play the blackmail
if you like of normal life.
- And by blackmail of normal
life in the sense that...
Normal life wants to put you
in a certain way of thinking.
- Yes, right, exactly.
Well, not just way of thinking,
but whole mode of comportment,
the whole set of priorities
for what are your life goals
and what's acceptable behavior
of various kinds, yeah.
- Your first book, which
I guess came out of your
dissertation, was letters
of the republic, publication
and the public sphere
in 18th century America.
Help us understand your
contribution there.
In other words, it was known that...
An important change occurred
in the various kinds
of journals, letters and
newsletters that were coming
into being before the time
of the revolution and after.
- Yes, in fact the going
theory at the time was
that this was just the natural consequence
of print technology.
There was a very important book
by Elizabeth Eisenstein
called the Printing Press
Is an Agent of Change and so it was...
A well accepted area of
inquiry, how did printing
change culture, it seemed
to me that that way
of telling the story
was too one directional
or one dimensional, that...
Before it was possible for
print to really change much
in social life, you had to
have a certain perception
of print, a certain way
of using print and because
I was working in literary
study, this seemed like
a natural thing to think about.
It was also probably important
that I was working in
colonial American literature,
which is a...
Funny little byway in
English studies because
the colonial period in American literature
doesn't have major novelists.
The American novel
doesn't start until after
the revolution, it
doesn't have major poets
of, like, Wordsworth or Milton so...
What does colonial
American literature mean?
Usually ended up meaning
people who were writing things
for purposes other than
literary consumption,
Benjamin Franklin, for
example, so the field kind of
lent itself readily to
someone who wanted to look at
a wide range of uses of
print and think about
what is the standing of
a text in the culture.
- And it's here that you
begin to develop your theories
of public and counterpublic.
- Yeah.
- Especially the notion
of how a new public came into being.
- Yeah.
- And it's not as you just said,
just that print changed everything.
It was rather the audience contributing
to what print could be.
- Exactly.
And therefore new ways
of writing and publishing
to reach an audience
like that, the concept
of the public, which
we now take for granted
as part of our social world really emerged
at the very beginning of the 18th century
and so that was a very
striking fact to me.
It was trying to understand
that or trying to understand
what are the different
practices of writing
and publication that go with that concept,
that make that concept
seem natural or that
follow from the availability
of that concept?
That's what I wanted to think about.
At the time, the pathbreaking
work of Jorgan Habermas
on the public sphere was still
untranslated into English.
I had to read it, I don't read
German, so I had to read it
in a French translation,
the English translation
came out in the late 80s and...
I had groped my way toward a
lot of the same perceptions
or the same themes, so
it was, in retrospect,
the right moment in history
to be thinking about that.
- And the picture that
emerges in your book,
I'm trying to come up with a term,
it's the...
Written word and its
relation to its audience
is almost like a very good
seminar with discussion.
So that the people who are
reading are also engaging and
feeding into the creation of a community.
- Well, that's the theory.
- Yeah, that's the theory.
- Now in fact, the concept
of the public derived from
broadcast modes of
publication, which don't have
that closed circle of
community discussion at all.
In fact, they succeed to the
degree that they sell more
copies, get more distribution than...
The responses come back.
- Right.
- So it's asymmetrical.
Broadcast publication is
crucially asymmetrical,
it's the whole structure.
- But in your book,
as you come to terms with the public,
it's very different from the
public as we know it today.
- Oh, of course, yes,
because broadcast media
were really all that there were then
and there was no such
thing as social media.
- Right.
- But that's another subject,
is how it's changed today,
but in the world dominated
by broadcast printing
and later by broadcast electronic media,
asymmetry is very important
and so in order for it to
really look like the
culture of a democracy,
sometimes the response had to be faked.
Letters to the editor were
often written by the editors.
It was important for it to look
like a two way conversation
even when the interests of
the publishers was often in
maximizing the imbalance.
- So then your theory as
it emerges in the book
is really about a
possibility, the implications
of what was really going on.
- Yes, so there are
several key things I think
to understanding the way
media works in this kind of
modern society and one is
that there is an imaginary
uptake of what the social
world is, that is you
look at a printed object and you are,
without even knowing that
you make this assumption,
you are assuming that
countless strangers are
also looking at the same thing.
- We're talking about the colonial period.
- The colonial period but
also the contemporary period
when we're looking at broadcast media.
- Okay.
- So the background awareness
of all those unseen strangers
is a key part of how the
whole phenomenon works.
It's not just that you
read a book that was copied
by a scribe in your monastery
and only three people
have read it, or, you know, if
that's what the situation is
you're not dealing with a
public in the modern sense.
So there's an imaginary
uptake about what the nature
of the social world is and
that gives a special prominence
to the coexistence of strangers.
I think this has been the
great theme of all the work
I've done on publics, is the
primacy of stranger sociability
in the forms of modern life and
that's really transformative
and it's not something that people notice
because it is so much at
the level of their imaginary
uptake, their background assumptions about
how language circulates in the world.
So strangers come to have a
different importance to us.
They're not just foreigners
who happen to be traveling
through your village,
they're not just people away
off somewhere that you don't
have anything to do with,
they can be intimately
involved in your world and
of course nationalism is one expression of
how people can imagine
themselves as being related
to strangers, but all
kinds of public debates
and social movements and
counter movements are formed by
people's willingness
to think of themselves
as coinvolved with strangers.
- And what then becomes important
in this early period is...
The discourse involved
ideas of citizen autonomy,
republicanism, so they
become the vehicle for
a common language that is
the basis of our democracy.
- Exactly, so if you are
suddenly finding yourself
in a world where you are
writing to an audience
of strangers, how do you
understand the difference between
who you are as someone
speaking to strangers
and who you are in the rest of your life?
That difference can be pretty marked.
And in the 18th century,
there's a language
of political thought called
republicanism in which
the fate of the republic is
in the hands of the people
who have enough virtue
to put the common good
above their own private
good, so this language of
the common as opposed to the private was
what enabled people to speak to strangers
in this broadcast environment in that way.
- And does the recognition
of a world of strangers
then legitimize the
conversation in some way?
- Absolutely, and also shapes it, so...
You are speaking to strangers in the cases
that we're talking about
in a public sphere,
you are speaking to
strangers whom you imagine
as your contemporaries
and whom you imagine as
coinvolved in the life of your society.
And that shapes things in a lot of ways.
It means that your sense of
history is organized around
the rhythms of publication
and reception and answering
dialogs in public debate, so...
It became habitual for people
to think of print or public
language as...
Positioned on a timeline of the present.
Again, in contrast to the
reading of a manuscript
that might have been lying
around for decades or centuries
without losing any of its urgency,
things became contemporary
and newspapers, of course,
are the greatest marker of that.
They carry their date on the front page
and they circulate in
a very short timeframe.
- Why was Benjamin Franklin
such a pivotal figure
in this transformation?
- Well, I think, the obvious
answer, the short answer
is because he was a printer.
And he was an extremely astute
printer who realized that
the business he was in...
Was transformative.
And he had encounters
early in his life that set that imprint.
He was an apprentice in his
brother's print workshop
when his brother got into
trouble with the authorities
and his newspaper was
briefly printed over his name
as a sort of ruse to get
around the censorship.
So he understood early on that
printing was a kind of rival
to traditional forms of authority
and that you could
appeal to strangers in...
A persona, under a
pseudonym or anonymously
and thus veil yourself.
And make that separation
between the common good
and your private life very
sharp by not even appearing
in your own name.
Most of what Benjamin
Franklin wrote, he did not
except for his correspondence,
he did not write
under his own name and that I think
was a transformative recognition.
He was ahead of the curve
on how public discourse
was going to work in the modern world.
- This case study is one in which the...
Focus is on the emergence of a public
and it's a new public.
- Yeah.
- So there is social transformation by...
What in the beginning must
have been a marginal group
but which in effect changed the world.
- Yes.
- And the world became,
so this may be the ideal that...
Is missing in other, your later
works where you're focused
on the marginal, protecting the integrity
of the marginal groups
and you see that as a way
of potentially transforming the whole.
- Yes, that's true,
although the other thing
to be said there is that the
dynamics are not unrelated,
that is...
When you get a counterformation,
a social movement for example,
it is formed through the
same kinds of stranger
sociability as the dominant
public and has the same...
Contemporaneity, the same
relation to a social emergence
that the dominant public has, so...
One of the points that I
make in the essay on publics
and counterpublics is
that counterpublics are
publics too, and they're
formed by the same
media infrastructures,
it's not just that you have
local communities of dissent.
You have communities of
dissent that have the same
dynamics of public formation
that we see in the dominant culture.
- But...
It is the case that the ability of the...
Marginal groups to transform the whole...
That capacity is not one
that is as easily realizable.
- That's right, exactly, yes.
- Right, okay.
So your insights that
emerge in the first book
is really an ideal, not
subsequently as easily realizable.
- That's right, well...
That's also been a theme in...
In a variety of inquiries into this topic.
Habermas himself famously argued that the
public sphere was a kind of
ideal in the 18th century
that was betrayed by modern
societies in the 19th century.
When public media
increasingly became vehicles
of advertising so that the
public would be in a sense
sold to the advertisers
as a potential audience
for consumption and so on
and liberal editors agreed
to draw certain boundaries
around the sphere
of acceptable discussion,
so even there in Habermas
and this was a book that was
written in German in the 60s,
there was a strong emphasis
on the way the ideal
had never fully been realized, in fact,
Habermas was working on
the Frankfurt School's idea
of imminent critique,
that what you needed to do
in order to criticize
bourgeois society was not
bring to bear on it
extraneous criteria of value
but judge it by its own ideals.
Hold it to its own best version of itself
and the best version of
liberal bourgeois society
is that in the ideal of the public sphere,
as a place where people
can argue or contribute
representations of the good
life from any point of view
whatsoever, in fact it
doesn't work that way
but imagining that it
might turns out to be
a powerful way of seeing one
of the limits of this society.
- In your book, which I
think takes its title from
the essay you just talked about, Publics
and Counterpublics,
you talk a lot about...
The emergence of counterpublics, that is,
and tell us a little about counterpublics
and how they are in a way like publics
but in some ways different.
- Well, the impetus for
this came from thinking
about social movements
in the 20th century,
the women's movement, the gay movement,
civil rights movement,
how are those publics?
And this was a much debated topic once
Habermas's book got
translated into English
and I realized that once you
started thinking about it,
the existence of counterpublics
goes all the way back
to the emergence of the
concept of the public.
It was no sooner imagined
that strangers could be
organized this way than
people began to imagine...
Rival or excluded groups
organizing themselves
in the same way and in
fact, by my current research
is about how early
evangelicalism can be understood
as a kind of counterpublic.
Evangelicalism that emerged
in the 18th century is...
Significantly distinguished
from previous versions
of Protestantism by its
willingness to preach to strangers.
And by the aggressive use of public media.
And so the Protestant
religion got reoriented around
the language of conversion
that allowed people to think of
address to strangers as the
primary mode of religiosity
so in that sense, evangelicalism is a...
Strong example of the new
mentality of the public sphere.
However, it was also combative
and it understood itself
as trying to call people out
of the, what it understood
as the dominant culture.
Didn't have the language of the secular
to name that dominant
culture, but that language
grew out of this conflict, so
you have an interesting split
emerging in the 18th century
between the increasingly
secular world of the political public,
Benjamin Franklin again
being a key example,
and the counterformation of...
People who saw the same public
media as an opportunity for
conversionsistic outreach.
- You make a great deal of the fact that
these countercultures have the potential
because of the way they're using the media
and they're addressing strangers
to transform the whole,
basically.
- Yes.
- So there is an emphasis on...
Media but also how the
media in different hands
becomes something different.
This theory is very applicable
to what's going on now
and I want to draw that
out of you in a way.
In other words, social
media of the electronic
and internet kind is new, and
what we've witnessed recently
is the...
Emergence of a counterpublic
that has many of the characteristics
that you describe in your--
- You're thinking of the
alt right for example.
- Yeah, yeah, the alt
right, and let me just quote
something that you say
here, public discourse
says not only, that is for this...
Counterpublic, let the public exist.
But let it have this character.
Speak this way, see the world in this way.
It then goes in search of confirmation
that such a public exists
with greater or less success
being further attempts to
cite, circulate and realize
the world understanding it articulates.
- Yeah, well, okay, so you
can see how the alt right
is a version of that because
in that world it's understood
that American means person like us,
so this is a way that...
This is a bit of a paradox
and it's a complication that
counterpublics very often
think of themselves as...
Publics in waiting, that
is to say as striving to be
the dominant public and as
giving voice to what they think
should be the dominant public
and this is a really good example
because the alt right of course knows
that it's embattled and in a way minor.
But...
Also...
Aspires to be the dominant public itself
and that contradiction
is visible everywhere
so people will speak
with rage and resentment
and hostility that marks their awareness
of being marginal.
At the same time they will
act as though all good
Americans already agree with us
and so they're trying
to realize their version
of what it means to be a
member of the American public.
- How have their actions as
a counter, if we look at them
as a counterpublic, how
have they changed the media,
the new electronic media
which they have seized on
to build up their base?
- Well, it might be
better to put the question
the other way around.
- Okay.
- Because they've realized
that we inhabit different
media ecology now and...
The publics and counterpublics
essay came out in 2002.
We didn't have social media then.
But I did already understand
that something was changing
with the availability of the internet
because that rhythm of
contemporaneity that allows us
to know where we stand in
history with all these other
strangers who stand with us in history
was beginning to shift.
So instead of weekly
newspapers or daily newspapers,
you suddenly had 24/7 access of websites.
And that sense of time
has continued to evolve
in social media.
But more profoundly I think
the social media break,
the broadcast model that's always been
the underpinning of our sense of a public
so rather than sending...
Material out as far and wide
from one point as you can,
in the late 20th century,
for example, we had three
broadcast networks that really
dominated everybody's sense
of what the news was, suddenly
you've got as many points
of origin as there are people and...
People imagine the texture
of their public world more
in terms of networks
than in terms of publics.
And that has fractured
the language of the public
in a really profound way
and I don't think anyone knows
quite how to handle that.
Broadcast media still
exists and so we still have
the sense that there is
something like the national
public out there, but you can see from...
You can see from polling numbers,
from the persistence of a very
large percentage of America
that seems quite immune to the news
that the rest of America's absorbing,
that the public no longer
exists, if it ever did
as a single sutured space.
- And this undoubtedly
contributes to the fragmentation
of American politics.
- Well, absolutely.
- Yeah.
- Yes, absolutely and
therefore too, the...
Strength of resentment, because...
I think all parties are quite exasperated
by their inability to reach this putative
national public.
- And what do you see as
the long term implications
of this, is it just
continued fragmentation?
- That's the fear, of course.
- Yeah.
- One has no idea, I mean,
one couldn't really have
predicted this state of
affairs 20 years ago,
so who knows how this
media ecology will evolve,
but I think it's quite
scary in its implications.
So much of what we understand
as democracy or as self
governance has to do with the
ability of a world of media
to hold itself together and to...
Be a space of mutual respect
and mutual accommodation,
that when we no longer believe
that that space exists,
you have all kinds of very
scary opportunities for
fascistic and other kinds
of politics to emerge.
- Let's talk a little now about your book
The Trouble With Normal, a book that is
most known for its
criticism of gay marriage.
And again, this book was
written in the 1990s, I think.
- That's right, when the idea of marriage
was still a controversial
one within the gay movement
and did not yet seem to
be an inevitable future.
There was a lot of
argument among gay people
about whether this was the
right priority for the movement
or whether it was the be all
and end all of the movement
as some people were proposing.
- Two ideas that struck me in that book
and there are many there,
one is the extent to which
the institution of marriage
was a sector of privilege,
that excludes those who are not married
and talk a little about
that because it's a set
of privileges, rights
to custody of children,
rights to inheritance, and all,
medical coverage at that time.
Talk a little about that
because that's very important.
- Well, it is, in the popular imagination,
marriage is just one thing,
it's a kind of recognition
of a loving relationship.
And that's the way it was
being sold to gay people.
We have love just the
way straight people do,
why shouldn't it be
recognized just the way
straight people's love was recognized?
Well, fine, except that
marriage isn't exactly that.
You can have marriage without
love and you can have love
without marriage and so
that didn't seem like
a very satisfactory
account of what marriage is
and when you started to look into it
you realize that marriage
is an enormous bundle
of different privileges and obligations.
You get your spouse...
Has special access to medical
care and to death rights
and to disposition of the
body and hospital visitation
and childcare and all kinds
of other things that...
We just take for granted
as a single package,
but that hasn't always been the case
and it isn't always the
case in other legal systems
like the French legal
system, so I wanted to just
drive a little space
between the language of love
and recognition and the
actual politics of what...
On the ground happens
when people get married
because it seemed to me that
gay people who had lived
without this institution for a long time
had developed their own
patterns of intimacy
and their own patterns of social life
and their own patterns of mutual care,
especially after the AIDS crisis,
it was a very robust world
of mutual care and it
seemed that it was suddenly
being shoehorned into this model around
the monogamous couple and...
We weren't thinking creatively
about other ways that
those rights and obligations
might be distributed
among your intimacies, why not...
Think about experiments in
this form, like the French
were doing at the time?
And I thought that language
about how marriage is just love
was what was preventing
people from thinking about
other possibilities.
- And the second point
that emerges is the...
Extent to which the...
Counterpublic...
Represents...
Variations in the way
people relate to each other.
- That's right.
- Which...
Has an integrity of its own and...
Should be respected and importantly...
By letting gays marry, you
threaten that integrity
by coopting people into marriage.
- Well, that's certainly one
of the, part of the potential
and it depends not just
on the legal institution.
Because people can want
that legal institution
for all kinds of reasons, you
know, if you have a partner
and you're facing sickness
and death together,
marriage is a very useful tool
for protecting you from...
You know, homophobic families or whatever.
But to the degree that gay
people began to internalize
the idea that all we want as
gay people is to be accepted
into the mainstream and be
married just like straight people
they foreclosed all the
richness of public intimacies
in the gay world, they
foreclosed all the work
of experimentation that
queer people had been doing
for generations.
And I worried about that
especially because in the queer world,
memory is very fragile.
You don't learn from your
parents how the gay world
is structured, so there's
not a whole lot of
intergenerational transfer,
and it seemed to me
especially...
Dangerous that the...
Language of marriage would
just colonize the imagination
of younger gay people,
they would come of age
thinking, oh, yes, this is the experience,
this is the goal that
validates my experience
as a gay person, is marriage.
In fact, I think that has
happened for a certain stratum
in the gay world.
Fortunately, I think there's
also been a counter movement,
that is that a lot of
younger people coming of age
have been disillusioned by that language
and have seen its shallowness
and its falseness.
The trans movement has
been really powerful
in reawakening people
to all the exclusions
that are performed by
traditional gender identity
and marriage and so I think there is a...
Very powerful...
Movement in...
Gay life against the narrowing
that marriage represented
at the same time that
marriage can be a step
towards other kinds of recognitions.
I think it only works
that way if people refuse
the narrowing through which
marriage was sold to us.
- Two very different groups, the...
Queer community on the one hand,
the alt right on the other.
And in both cases, you
have counterpublics dealing
with the public, what
is your thinking about
the dynamic between
counterpublics and publics
because sometimes we may
want a greater realization
and sometimes we may not.
- Oh, absolutely so there's...
There's always a kind of oscillation.
This is the dynamic of
history and politics
in a society like ours,
is when is your public...
Trying to be the dominant public?
And when is it withdrawing?
And in a sense embracing
the barriers that exclude it
in order to create a
space of experimentation?
And I think both dynamics are important
and both dynamics have been
there in every movement,
including those evangelicals
I was talking about earlier
because you can see in
evangelicals a constant
oscillation between the idea of...
Drawing apart from the
mainstream society in order
to create this better,
reformed more Christian
way of life and insisting
that they represent
the Christian nation that's
been there all along.
I think just about every
counterpublic does that
to some degree or another
and so queer life has been,
in many ways, really
enabled by its marginality,
by its exclusion from the
open space of inspection
and surveillance and whatnot
that goes with being public.
- As I think about your
intellectual odyssey,
it seems that your evangelical beginnings
your movement to the secular
world, then into the...
History of the colonial
period, that there is a...
There is a...
Training ground for
perception of these dynamics.
Is that a fair assessment?
- I think that's accurate, although
these continuities only become
clear to me in retrospect.
It never is obvious at the time.
I have been very fortunate
in my life to be able
to move from one topic
of inquiry to another
and reinvent my expertise such as it is.
You know, many people
in the academic world
find a subspecialty and
go into it and own it
for the entirety of their careers
I have not been that kind of person.
I've always been attracted to those...
Topics or areas of
inquiry that no discipline
seems to own and no one seems
to have a good language for
so the public sphere.
When I started working on that,
what was that, was that political science,
was it literary study, was it history?
Was it philosophy, it
was all of those, and
secularism, later on,
in my life or queerness.
What discipline owned those topics and...
Those are the ones that
always seemed really exciting
to me and so I have experienced
myself at those moments
as leaping from one...
To another in a way that
required radical reeducation.
I've had to go off and...
Learn whole new bodies of work each time
and then it turns out I've been
working on the same problem
all along. (laughs)
- So if I were trying to
understand you better...
Is it fair to say you
are a social libertarian?
- Oh, I wouldn't use the
language of libertarian, no,
because that...
Presupposes that individual
freedom is the...
Foundational building block of everything.
I have a very strong
communitarian side, if you want
to think in terms of those oppositions.
I have always been interested in the way,
what counts to us as a meaningful freedom
is conditioned on our
participation in a life world
of others, and...
Queer life is a really
great example of that.
You can't really get very
far being gay or being queer
just by declaring your
personal liberty to be so.
You have to find other
people and you have to find
other people on a shared
mode of sociability
that allows you to be
gay or queer or whatever
in a way that will prove
to be satisfying to you.
And it's always a process of...
Mutual discovery and mutual elaboration.
So I think that...
I think this is the backbone
of the counter public concept
is that it is a life world of...
A life world transacted
among strangers, really.
That is the enabling
condition for anything
that would count as personal freedom.
- Your Tanner lectures
here will be put online
in audio form, but my sense
from hearing your first lecture
is that you're struggling
to find a counterpublic
with regard to climate change
and the environmental movement
but there is a concern
about its co-optation.
- Exactly, yes, right, so
in one way, it feels like
the gay marriage issue all
over again, and has strong
personal connections for
me because the particular
corner of the queer world
that I have the strongest
affinity to is a...
Network of radical fairies
that's built around
a system of communes, that
is, these are intentional
communities that date
from the off grid movement
of the 60s and 70s.
- And the off grid refers to
the grid, not the electric grid
- Yes, the electric
power grid, so there is,
the radical fairy world is a
really remarkable convergence
between, if you like, gay life
and the back to the land movement.
It's been around since
one of the founders of the gay movement
is a man named Harry Hay
who got dissatisfied with...
Mainstream organizing and
tried to steer gay life
toward this radically utopian
back to the land vision.
Now that was a long time ago,
but many of these communes
still exist and are organized
around ways of thinking
of community and experimentation that...
Off grid movement really sheltered, so.
When I look around now at climate change
and the importance of
the electrical power grid
to dealing with climate
change, I'm realizing
that there was a strong vision of...
What infrastructure ought
to be for a livable society,
what the grid represented,
how it wasn't exactly
the livable infrastructure
of a good society.
That that movement
developed in the 60s and 70s
and is now really increasingly forgotten
and foreclosed by the
necessity of reforming
the grid for climate change,
so I have taken up this
project partly as a way
of thinking about where
is this world headed
in the age of climate change?
What does it mean to be
alive at this moment?
But also, more particularly,
what can be retrieved
from that tradition of contrarian thought?
- One final question and
a brief answer if you can
'cause we're nearing the end of our time.
If our audience watches
this and they become attuned
to the notion of publics
and counterpublics,
is there something they
should think about,
what should they bring to
the focus on the conflict
between counterpublics and publics?
Is it liberal humanistic
values that help you
evaluate...
What a counterpublic has to contribute?
- Well, I suppose that's
true, and many of my friends
think that liberal is a bad word.
On the other hand, when Martha
Nusbaum reviewed my book
she called me the queer
John Stewart Mills,
so I guess I ought to own the label.
I think that liberalism is a kind of...
Problematic term because everyone thinks
they know what it is and
it's in fact a very fractious
and developing tradition
that can mean quite a lot
of different things, most people I know
who think of themselves as left critics
of liberalism nevertheless
have a lot of the principal values
of liberalism, like the harm principle.
And so I suppose yes, I do
have some central commitments
that I can recognize as being
part of the liberal tradition.
However, I am also trying
to be aware, constantly,
of what's excluded and
what are usually set
as the boundaries of acceptable behavior
in a liberal public sphere.
- Well, on that note,
Michael I want to thank you
very much for coming
to the Berkeley campus.
- Well, thank you.
- And taking the time
to be on our program.
- It's been a pleasure.
- And thank you very much
for joining us for this
conversation with history.
(electronic music)